so here's the question and you are asked
to solve right when you look at it you
think okay this is just this is just
normal algebra right so you start to do
your normal thing which is you expand
right and then you you collect the like
terms you like all clearly I have to
subtract 4x from both sides and then you
wait and you think hold on a second I
have a problem okay so then then you
raise the question what does this mean
okay now really for us we should have
looked at that first line that first
layer and right away we should have said
no solution
you shouldn't have needed to have gone
any further and I'll show you why now
I'm gonna walk you through the way that
I go through this the way that I think
through it and immediately how're you
gonna say really do you have to do that
the strategist no no you don't have to
do that it will take you some time to
get to the point where my way of looking
at it will become your way but there's a
reason why my way of looking at it is my
way of looking at it rather than having
to go through algebra this is a trivial
example sometimes not so trivial and
being able to see it from the beginning
is gonna save you a lot of time not to
mention it demonstrates better
understanding what does this statement
mean what a statement okay what it's
asking for when you have an equation and
you've got algebra involved right it's
saying when does this thing whatever it
is intersects with this thing whatever
it is okay this is simple thing so for
example when you see this right when you
see this don't think algebra first don't
think algebra first think about what is
this object and what is this right the
answer is left hand side is a parabola
so the parabola looks like this
and the right hand side is a horizontal
line which looks like this going through
one okay so what that question is posing
to you is well where did these two
coincide where they intersect and of
course that's why it's plus or minus one
now this is why I oppose from when
people say why is this have two
solutions whereas if I take this slide
and I take the square root of both sides
why does that only have one solution
okay and the reason why is because this
object is a parabola
and this object is what's something else
right and you can graph that and you can
look at it and it only has one solution
okay whereas this has two so now let me
come back to this you have a look at
that now this simple object linear okay
the further we go into the scene your
course the more you should start to get
used to seeing more sophisticated
objects and being able to visualize them
what are these things
I hope you can see this this equivalence
in your head without actually having to
write it down okay
so therefore what are those two well
they are two straight lines okay and
doing a bit of violence into my scale
here because of the gradients involved
four X plus eight is going to look
something like that and four X plus 9 is
going to look something like this that's
a really bad scale but you get the point
don't you right because they had the
same gradient they they're going forever
and they never meet they never intersect
there are none of these things there's
no solution no working required okay so
my overarching principle here and this
is actually very very relevant to the
inequalities you're doing - is that a
graphical way of doing this is almost
always a superior way of thinking about
a question right because then you can
explain why it isn't this solution not
just you arrive at something which is
mmm then you write no solution because
you don't know what else to write okay
you write some no solution because it's
an illustration - an explanation of
what's actually going on so that makes
it cool now I said I was going to go
back to a question in the last exercise
and I'll just quickly ask yeah yeah so
okay I I would probably do this I
probably do that I think that's a better
answer
but this because it's not true so and
whereas this actually says something
meaningful and when you get some more
complicated ones right where you like
the case you know the next one we got to
problem is right this actually makes a
statement about the two covers you know
almost certainly where is it going
the two Crowder's will be two pods of
projectile motion right and it'll be
like when do these objects collide and
your answer will be they never collide
and the reason we look at my awesome
diagram okay it doesn't have to be
beautiful by the way it just has to be
enough to illustrate what's going on